in the midst of all of the hubbub around
Ron DeSantis announcing he's running for
president Tim Scott announcing that he's
running Donald Trump spending 24 to 48
hours simply going after Ron DeSantis
everybody forgot about Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley the former governor of South
Carolina is also running for the
Republican nomination she is getting
absolutely no attention she's desperate
for relevance so what does she do
yesterday
she goes I don't know let me go
completely anti-transgender why not this
seems to be playing well among some now
she's not wrong the biggest Applause
lines for the last couple of years at
right wing events including CPAC and
others have been when speakers make fun
of or go after LGBT people it's a
Resurgence of that in the Republican
party so here is Nikki Haley figuring
out I guess how to get some attention
maybe people will choose her because
she's going to come out against trans
people in a disgusting way here's what
she had to say at politics and eggs in
New Hampshire
we've got by
lime where is everyone right my daughter
ran track in high school did she I
wouldn't even know how to have that
conversation with her how do we get our
girls comfortable with biological Boys
in their locker room
it's not okay
everybody know about Dylan Mulvaney
Bud Light right right make no mistake
right that is a guy dressed up like a
girl making fun of women women don't act
like that
get everybody's wondering why a third of
our teenage girls
seriously contemplated suicide last year
what are we doing to them we're supposed
to be growing strong girls confident
girls not ones being made fun of right
so one of the reasons that's actually
evidence-based for the increase in
suicidal ideation among particularly
teen girls but teens in general is
unrestricted access to social media
seems to be extremely damaging in many
different ways Cal Newport has a recent
podcast episode on this issue that I
highly recommend people listen to but
the idea among the anti-trans activists
that quote keeping men out of women's
sports that's how they call it we've got
to keep men out of women's sports they
pretend that it's a feminist issue a
women's issue
the claim that banning trans women from
Sports is a feminist issue number one
ignores the history and diversity of
actual feminism feminism feminism isn't
this monolithic movement it's a
compilation or combination of different
perspectives and goals that aim to
achieve what different people see as
gender equality and justice and there
are many feminists who support trans
rights and inclusion and they see trans
women as allies in a struggle against
whatever it is that they believe is the
most important thing to struggle against
and so part of the feminist movement
uh argues that when you exclude trans
women from women's spaces and activities
you're actually reinforcing the very
harmful stereotypes that feminism has
sought to undo but it's okay to
acknowledge that the so-called let's not
let's call it trans women in women's
sports to to try to put uh a less
offensive way to describe it that is a
difficult issue for some sports
in which physical Advantage comes from
muscle mass weightlifting would be one
example and I am the first to tell you
that although trans women and women's
sports
is an issue that is a slice of a slice
of a slice right you've got like all
political issues issues related to
gender within issues related to gender
issues that are under the trans category
under trans you have all sorts of
different issues bathrooms and all the
within that you've got okay Sports and
then a subsection of that would be
Sports in which muscle mass confers a
definitive Advantage so we're
understanding the scope right this is
not the biggest issue there are
different opinions about how it should
be handled
some say so you know 31 states have gone
the way of banning biological male
individuals from women's sports in some
capacity that's one approach summer
taking it's been done in 31 States as of
about a year and a half ago the number
may be slightly different now that's one
View
another approach is you let
trans women
biological males right different people
use different terms for this you allow
those individuals to compete in women's
sports if they meet certain criteria
such as undergoing uh hormone
suppression therapy for a certain period
of time as signed off on by a medical
professional the NCAA has gone in that
direction for some sports in some cases
another idea is for the sports in which
muscle mass confers a definitive
Advantage you create a separate category
for Trans athletes who don't fit into
the other binary categories there are
many who say that actually is going to
further stigma that's the last thing we
need the point is there is a
conversation to be had
about trans women
specifically in the sports where muscle
mass is really important Nikki Haley
talking about a guy named Dylan Mulvaney
who's with Bud Light sponsorship is just
disgusting uh pandering to the
anti-trans crowd but nobody's paying
attention to Nikki Haley and her
campaign was Dead on Arrival so she's
struggling for relevance